permettez moi de vous souhaiter de vie
voit au delà des cartes de voeux que
nous recevrons les uns et autres
tous mes voeux pour 2021 et nous
mettrons évidemment la santé sur le
dessus de la pile si vous me permettez
cette expression triviale
à l'occasion de la reprise donc de nos
travaux parlementaires nous appris
aujourd'hui monsieur sébastien lecornu
ministre d outre-mer affaire me faire un
point sur la politique du gouvernement
dans les outre-mer je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre d'avoir répondu
favorablement à notre invitation dans le
contexte sanitaire toujours très
préoccupant que nous connaissons c'est
la première fois que la délégation à
l'honneur de vous recevoir dans vos
nouvelles fonctions mais elle avait eu
l'occasion de vous entendre sur les
risques naturels majeurs dans les
outre-mer en votre qualité de secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre de la
transition écologique et solidaire en
janvier 2018 n'est pas si loin que ça
face aux légitimes inquiétudes de nos
concitoyens la présente édition est
d'abord l'occasion d'échanger sur
l'évolution de la pandémie de kobe 19
outre-mer et actualité oblige sur la
stratégie vaccinale retenue dont chaque
territoire en particulier concernant la
déclinaison du triptyque du ministre de
la santé accélérer et amplifier et
simplifier on connais ses soeurs de
michel magras avait coutume de dire que
les outre mer ont besoin d'une vision
claire d'engagement solide et surtout de
réalisations concrètes nous espérons que
vous pourrez monsieur le ministre nous
donner davantage d'éclairage sur la
situation et les perspectives pour les
outre-mer concernant une compagnie comme
vous le savez fait dans l'hexagone
l'objet de nombreuses critiques
la présente audition s'inscrit également
dans le prolongement de l'étude de notre
délégation sur l'urgence économique
outre-mer à la suite de la crise
sanitaire dont il ya un artigalas
nassimah dindar et moi même étions les
rapporteurs nous recevions ici même le
10 décembre dernier le président de la
fedom messieurs jean pierre philibert
qui a émis des doutes sur la réalité de
la somme de 1 2 5 milliards d'euros
consacrés aux plans de relance en outre
mer sa part ils l'avaient identifié qu
environ 200 millions d'euros de crédits
véritablement de nouveau c'est aurions
donc recueillir aujourd'hui vos
assurances même si vous aviez abordé le
sujet lors de l'examen des crédits de la
mission outre-mer
parmi nos préoccupations concernant
l'effectivité de la réalisation de ce
plan figurent le manque d' ingénierie
des collectivités ultramarines et les
modalités du plan de garantie de 200
millions d'euros visant à compenser les
pertes des recettes fiscales des
collectivités ultramarines
par ailleurs la france devrait
bénéficier du plan de relance européen
mais nous aimerions savoir comment les
autres maires vont en bénéficier et
comprendre l'articulation des
financements du plan de relance national
avec ceux du plomb ray actuels et du
budget européen 2021 2027
autre sujet d'actualité
le projet de loi 4d notamment son volet
différenciation territoriale des mégane
mon cher au président magra sur lequel
vous avez souhaité recueillir les
propositions des parlementaires en
novembre et qui sera soumis
prochainement au parlement nous
aimerions que vous nous détailler les
dispositions spécifiques aux autres
maires inscrite dans le projet de loi 4d
concernant notamment le transfert du
fond c'est via l' agence des 50 pas
géométriques aux antilles à la
régularisation des possesseurs son titre
à mayotte
au delà du nouveau du contenu de ce
projet de loi et à la suite du rapport
la délégation sur ce sujet sommes
nombreux à attendre la position du
gouvernement sur les propositions
sénatoriale qui figuré en particulier
celles concernant une évolution un style
constitutionnelle permettant de
consacrer pleinement la possibilité des
statuts à la carte pour les
collectivités ultramarines enfin la
question du logement dont les outre mer
figurent au programme de travail de
notre délégation sénatoriale pour 2021
le collègue guillaume gontard micheline
jack et victorin lurel ont été désigné
rapporteur
comme cela était amplement souligné lors
de la discussion budgétaire la sous
consommation des crédits affectés au
logement y récurrentes malgré les
besoins considérables
les résultats sur les plans continuent
sur le plan quantitatif et qualitatif du
premier plan 2015 2020 ont été peu
satisfaisant ce qu'a reconnu madame
annick girardin elle-même en juillet
2019 et le nouveau plan 2019 2022 peine
à se déployer
il ya notre connaissance son comité de
pilotage n'a toujours pas été réunies
nous souhaiterions dans le cadre de
cette étude nous attacher aux dynamiques
à soutenir et amplifier pour construire
plus et mieux en outre-mer l'étude de
pourrait par ailleurs être l'occasion
d'insister sur le rôle des outre-mer
comme laboratoire d'innovation et de
différenciation
je laisserai aux rapporteurs prison le
soin de vous interroger plus précisément
sur les différents aspects de cette
réflexion qui va nous occuper au cours
des prochains mois je vous propose donc
de faire le point dans votre exposé
liminaire monsieur le ministre sur ces
différents sujets en vous basant sur la
trame qui vous a été adressé je ne doute
pas que mes collègues présents et ceux
qui participent aux visioconférences et
que je salue également aurons l'occasion
de vous adresser de nombreuses questions
avant de vous céder la parole je vous
précise que la présente audition fait
l'objet d'une captation vidéo
retransmise en direct sur le site
internet du sénat et qu'elle sera
consultable en vidéo à la demande et
pour respecter les contraintes d'agenda
des ministres que je vous indique que
nous disposons d'un créneau horaire
d'environ deux heures ce qui devrait
nous permettre malgré tout d'aborder un
certain nombre de sujets mais les
ministres vous avez la parole
merci beaucoup monsieur le président à
mon tour je me permets de vous présenter
mes voeux je sais pas quelle est la
coutume au sénat sur le masque pour
l'orateur s'il ya une tolérance pour le
le citron le gars des vues
je me pose juste en les distançant
devrait on devrait pouvoir le faire à
mon tour de vous adresser évidemment
mais mes meilleurs voeux pour cette
année heureux d'ouvrir aussi le bal des
travaux là de la délégation en salle ont
une nouvelle fois j'avais fait la
tribune du sénat
pendant la discussion budgétaire mais
évidemment le travail que votre
prédécesseur le sénateur m'a grave ça a
pu accomplir et ma jeu de vous retrouver
ce matin en se levant évidemment les
présidents de groupes de vip
le vice-président du sénat mon
prédécesseur le ministre lurel et
l'ensemble des sénatrices et sénateurs
ici présent j'ai vu qu'ils avaient pas
mal de questions donc j'ai peut-être
effectivement me contenter d'un propos
liminaire qui dit un tout petit peu ce
que j'essaie de faire depuis six mois et
est un peu quel est le plan de charge et
le plan de bataille pour l'année 2000
ce qui va permettre de parler
d'objectifs politiques puis ensuite à
travers les questions viendra peut-être
aux outils et les moyens qui nous
permettent de remplir ses objectifs et
trop souvent d'ailleurs sur les
questions d'être à marine on mélange ce
que l'on veut faire pour nos territoires
et nos concitoyens et les différents
outils que l'on veut que l'on veut
mettre en place et nos concitoyens et
même nos collègues élus locaux à la
rigueur se moque bien parfois des outils
ils ont bien raison il s'intéresse
surtout à notre capacité collective à
sortir des résultats peut-être la
première des choses
pardon mais comme ailleurs évidemment
locaux vides et le dossier qui nous qui
nous évidemment nous prendre plus de
temps et pour cause si on devait retenir
deux trois choses sur la gestion du coc
vise en outre mer un déjà un élément de
constat on a des chiffres qui sont
évidemment très différent en fonction
des territoires et je passe un temps
important ici à paris dans l'hexagone a
expliqué que le virus ne circulait pas
de manière uniforme
les sénateurs beltrame a ici le savent
mais le caractère bloc que l'on peut
avoir sur l'hexagone au sur un plateau
continental par définition au milieu
insulaire et en plus dans des conditions
climatiques qui sont très différentes
que celles nous connaissons en ce moment
même à paris fait que le virus circule
très différemment et pour cause entre
votre territoire monsieur le président
où alice et futuna et la nouvelle
calédonie
en mauvais français des territoires qui
sont co vite free parce que des mesures
de protection à la frontière ont été
prises avec des septs hainaut des 14 n
au début de la pandémie on n'est pas du
tout dans la même situation que des
territoires dans lequel on a parfois
connu un premier confinement puis un
deuxième confinement de manière
différenciée
je regarde et parlementaires de guyane
et de mayotte parce qu'évidemment ils
ont été largement concerné par cette
affaire
par deux fois en couches successives et
puis aujourd'hui si on y regarde de près
on les territoires qui sont toujours que
vie de free ces territoires dans lequel
les taux d'incidence sont extrêmement
bras et c'est le cas à la réunion
et évidemment aux antilles
spécifiquement la martinique et en
guadeloupe et même à saint martin sur
lequel ne serait des taux d'incidence
tenez vous bien de -30% 1000 quand on
regarde les chiffres aujourd'hui que
nous connaissons dans l'hexagone
cela doit nous faire réfléchir avec pour
le coup un système évidemment aux
sanitaires qui tient avec un taux de
positivité qui est au dessus d'un bon
vin qui est tenu et puis à côté de ça
évidemment vous avez des territoires qui
vivent des rythme particulier la guyane
je veux saluer les deux sénateurs de
guyane j'ai vu georges patient en visio
et évidemment glace et un tri finale ici
présente un sommaire de cayenne là pour
le coup on a de nouveau nommé prise une
reprise de l'épidémie assez importante
mais là aussi les territorialisée la
guyane c'est grand comme le portugal
est ce que le taux d'incidence est le
même à saint georges de l'oyapock à
saint-laurent-du-maroni ou gélules de
cayenne réponse est non et en fait ce
qui est intéressant chaque fois c'est
devant regard des taux d'incidence
donner beaucoup de précisions
on s'aperçoit qu'il aux alentours de 400
sur l'île de cayenne
là où le redescend sur certains villages
du fleuve donc là où je veux en venir
c'est que on peut pas appliquer de
manière uniforme et brutale des mesures
de freinage des situations très
différentes
alors ça ça a l'air facile à dire comme
ça en fait ça n'a pas été facile à
mettre en oeuvre et donc ça nous a pour
le coup permis de réussir quelque chose
que je revendique 1 vous m'excuserez
mais une très grande déconcentration de
la gestion de la crise sanitaire
en clair c'est dû aux préfets des gds
avec les élus je tiens à saluer parce
que j'ai veillé à ce qu'il soit associé
évidemment au partout et évidemment les
validations parce que vous
entre l'élection du gouvernement donc il
faut bien un moment donné évidemment que
les décisions soient validées et cela a
évidemment fait l'objet dé rendu compte
qu'il va bien donc sur la stratégie que
vite je pourrais venir
peut-être y mettre un message plus
pessimistes et sur lequel je veux
besoins des parlementaires pour faire
passer les messages
c'est que si le taux d'incidence aussi
la circulation du virus a été un élément
important pour décider des mesures de
freinage ça tombe sous le sens désormais
la question des variants va venir
largement impacter notre stratégie ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'on va
être amenée par exemple à prendre des
mesures plus fortes en guyane avant tout
parce que le taux d'incidence augmente
désormais la chose est connue
la stratégie de différenciation aussi je
le dis parce que souvent ça fait ça fait
bondir au moment où nous parlons les
restaurants sont ouverts aux antilles
évidemment ils sont même ouverts en
guyane bon parce qu'on est tout
simplement les restaurants servent en
extérieur parce que on a on a des
protocoles sanitaires qui ont été
adaptés à des défis climatiques qui
complètement différente que celle de
paris en ce moment ça il faut
l'expliquer faut le porter parce
qu'évidemment ce n'est pas complètement
banale dans la question du variant
disais-je est évidemment une question
sur lequel sera amenée avec le miz de la
santé a à prendre la parole et associer
les différents élus des différents
territoires dans les tout prochains
jours
on le voit bien notamment sur mayotte et
à la réunion sur lequel actuellement on
mène un certain nombre de deux contrôles
parce que la question ne variant 10 501
en afrique du sud et donc sur une partie
du plateau continental africain
évidemment nous interroge beaucoup sur
les mesures de protection à prendre
c'est là va falloir expliquer à nos
concitoyens également monde économique
que désormais on va prendre peut-être
des mesures de protection qui sont pas
des mesures de protection qui s'appuie
sur le taux d'incidence tel qu'on le
regarde
c'est la nouveauté c'est sur les mesures
de protection pour se prémunir de la
pénétration et la circulation dudit
variant en question le 501 de type dit
sud africain mais je pense qu'il ne faut
pas l'appeler sud africain parce que les
sud africains
on fait le séquençage de ceux de ce
variant et je pense que pour un pays ami
il n'est pas de bon ton de commencer l
affublé d'une nationalité ce variant
donc on va les qualifier de 500 à l'eau
si je pourrai répondre à vos questions
puis bien sûr la stratégie de
vaccination sur lequel vous pourrez
évidemment le point de vos questions sur
lequel si on se dit quelques mots très
rapidement déjà il y avait des enjeux
logistique et pour cause ces fameux
congélateur alors quand on est sur des
doses qui a qui fonctionne à -20°
évidemment on retombe sur des
technologies que l'on a déjà bien
souvent de manière de mystique lorsqu'on
est sûre les deux amants 87° balazs
finement ddd réfrigérateurs congélateurs
pardon évidemment à doc était un enjeu
logistique grâce aux armes et nous avons
relevé désormais les différents
territoires sont équipés et donc en fait
on a une stratégie de vaccination qui se
déploie au même rythme que sur
l'hexagone
là aussi c'était pas forcément gagné sur
le terrain logistique mais je tiens à
saluer évidemment les professionnels de
santé mais aussi tout simplement les
centres hospitaliers parce que dans une
culture insulaire
le centre hospitalier il est quand même
le point de convergence du bassin
sanitaire est donc là aussi j'ai pu m'en
rendre compte à à pointe à pitre encore
pour le jour de l'an
alors en martinique également enfin en
clair les centres hospitaliers sont
plutôt armée pour le faire l'ona cette
convergence qui va bien la vraie
question et le sénateur gani en sait
quelque chose c'est évidemment que dans
certains territoires ya pas d pad où on
a une autre manière de prendre soin de
ses anciens dans un milieu évidemment de
solidarité intergénérationnelle enfin
des choses se baptisent différemment et
donc là évidemment on va adapter les
stratégies de vaccination aux réalités
on peut pas dire on commence par les
épate ya pas d pad ça veut dire qu'on
n'a pas commencé donc là évidemment on
trouve on trouve les solutions qui vont
bien je suis pas trop long parce que je
connais mon caractère bavard mais je
suis le co vide évidemment si vous devez
retenir quelque chose c'est qu'on a on a
cherché à avoir une stratégie locale
très différenciée qui n'est pas sans
poser des questions parfois depuis paris
compris des journalistes des
observateurs et qui en même temps me
semble-t-il est évidemment bien vécu
localement parce qu'elle s'appuie sur la
réalité des circulations du
ce qui a pu nous nous conduire à des
choses étonnantes en tout cas aux
antilles c'est d'avoir la martinique ont
confiné parce que les chiffres n'étaient
pas ou alors que la guadeloupe ne
l'était pas et ce qui d'ailleurs a pu
susciter des questions entre les deux
territoires en disant mais pourquoi les
autres et pas nous bah tout simplement
parce qu'on n'avait pas la même
circulation du virus est qu on a adapté
des choses il faut pas que nos villes
nous empêche de de travailler sur deux
autres sujets me semble rejeter ce sont
évidemment les grands sujets de
transformation sur lequel d'ailleurs moi
je le dis et victorin lurel m'a entendu
le dire dans l'hémicycle lors de la
discussion budgétaire
je m'inscris avec beaucoup d'humidité
dans la continuité de ce que mes
prédécesseurs et ce que des
gouvernements précédents on tentait de
faire et on est on réussit parfois
parfois les plus difficulté
c'est un mec et des sujets qui font des
sujets de long cours sur les enjeux des
différents territoires d'outre-mer et
j'amènerai dans un instant est au fond
la relance économique c'est là je serai
le tuilage elle est un objet lundi un
mot tout de suite mais elle est aussi un
outil tac
elle est un objet pour le sauvetage du
tissu économique mais ça on le fait déjà
avec la mesure d'urgence au passage je
rappelle que on a adapté aussi des
mesures d'urgence je récite mayotte
guyane sur lequel on avait pris des
mesures différenciation sur le fond de
solidarité et pour cause quand on est
confiné une deuxième fois par définition
ce que l'hexagone n'avait pas connu il
fallait bien adapter les choses puis
parfois on a aussi des secteurs qui sont
quand même plus ou moins ouverts par la
régie magie de tourisme c'est pas pour
autant qu'on a on a débranché les
mesures d'accompagnement qu'elle est
bien en face parce que c'est pas parce
qu'on est ouvert qu'on fonctionne comme
d'habitude donc ça aussi il a fallu
différencier des mesures
d'accompagnement d'urgence vous
connaissez des sommes on a beaucoup
parlé de tout ça pendant la discussion
du plf
je n'y reviens pas donc le plan de
relance j'ai entendu vos questions
président tanoh il ya un enjeu c'est
évidemment de réussir cette
territorialisation alors que les
sénateurs de l'hexagone ici présents ne
le prennent pas mal ou ne repartent pas
avec des inquiétudes après tout moi
aussi j'ai un petit côté sénateurs
hexagonal je pense qu'on a plus de
chance de réussir vite la
territorialisation du plan de relance en
outre mer que dans l'exacte
dire qu'on va l'arrêter dans l'hexagone
ne me faites pas dire ce que je te dis
je dis juste que les projets sont connus
en outre mer que par définition le
nombre d'acteurs n'est pas infinie je
veux dire si entre le préfet le
président de la collectivité
territoriale du coin nous le présent de
régions et présente département le cas
échéant les patrons de pci les
parlementaires et les deux trois grandes
filières qui structurent unis louent ou
le territoire de la guyane
si on n'est pas capable de très vite
sentir les clio crochet
doit on a vraiment besoin qui font
consensus et pour cause parce que
parfois il existe depuis des années ils
ont fait l'objet de dix campagnes
électorales des uns et des autres bon je
vous parle très librement
normalement on est capable très vite
devoir de voir qu'il ya un problème nous
en guadeloupe quoi je dirais donc on a
besoin de remettre de l'argent sur les
réseaux d'eau on joue très vite on est
capable de voir qu'on a un plan séisme
antilles qu'il faut accélérer très vite
on voit bien qu'on a d'un enjeu de
logement à la réunion pas que je donne
des exemples comme ça parce que il faut
pas qu'on se raconte des histoires la
meilleure des relances parfois c'est
d'accélération ce qui est déjà engagée
on va pas commencer à réinventer la
poudre en lisant ces plans de relance
faisons que ça soit plus ceci plus cela
- machin non je pense qu'il faut qu'on
soit dans une logique très clair c'est
de se dire qu'il ya des grands enjeux
ils sont identifiés il existe parfois
faudra tout simplement dans une logique
d'accélération ça aussi j'y reviendrai
et je crois que la question du logement
dal et relança etat c est assez
importante non il faut que la relance
est mon troisième point permet de nous
emmener sur des chantiers de
transformation
moi je resterai militants d'avancer très
vite avec sa dimension de l'état qui
protège sur les risques naturels et en
martinique aux côtés des sinistrés des
intempéries récents nous nous constituer
en hexagone oublie trop souvent que dans
la république aujourd'hui on a les
citoyens qui sont exposées à des risques
sismiques à des risques volcaniques à
des risques d'érosion évidemment ans
reviendrait sur la transition écologique
shao prison tard mais évidemment il ya
des choses sur lesquelles on peut
avancer
j'avais un instant au risque évidemment
ouragans cyclones en fonction des des
hémisphères
enfin globalement à part les avalanches
tous les risques naturels sont présents
d'une manière ou d'une autre en
outre-mer bon et le reste
mon climatique on le voit bien vient
accélérer en plus ces risques naturels
et donc c'est toute la question de la
résidence qui est posée est donc cette
accélération là on peux pas la regarder
de manière passive donc des choses sont
déjà aussi l'enclencher gilles devers
eux cité le plan séisme antilles mais
pas que les enjeux autour d'eux des
érosions 2d trait de côte qui sont des
sujets évidemment hyper important sans
compter sans compter évidemment déçu
j'ai beau diversité sa jetée sur les
risques naturels
on doit pouvoir avancer vite il ya des
mesures effectivement qui vont peut-être
trouver niche dans le projet de loi
cadre des jeux c'est qu'il y avait des
questions sur le projet de loi sur les
risques naturels majeurs
la réalité c'est qu'en fait et moi j'ai
pris ma part en fumée émise et outre-mer
c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de mesures qui
relèvent du réglementaire pour des
raisons politiques il était de bon ton
peut-être de les mettre dans un texte de
loi parce que ça nous permettait de le
faire tous ensemble moi je vous parle
très franchement je ne sais pas
expliquer à nos concitoyens aux élus
locaux qui sait qu'on va retarder des
mesures parce qu'on les met dans une loi
alors que j'aurais pu les prendre par
décret un pou li très très très
tranquillement donc on va avancer sur le
terrain réglementaire
ce qui ne veut pas dire président que la
délégation et le parlement sera ne sera
pas associé
là aussi évidemment si vous souhaitez un
jour qu'on ait une séance de travail
dédié à cette seule question des risques
naturels de nouveau avec un peu
d'opérationnalité
je suis évidemment prêt à le faire la
deuxième des choses et à la réunion on a
quelques promesses agricole amont et
vicky qui sont qui sont intéressantes
c'est travailler sur je me méfie du mot
souveraineté parce que parfois il est
chez certains certaines sensibilités
politiques ultra marines il récupère un
mauvais comptes parce que la
souveraineté suscite peut-être une
question liée à l'indépendance
donc on peut parler d'auto suffisance
enfin vous y mettrez le mot que vous
voulez mais dans les territoires
insulaires en tout cas il n'est pas
normal d'être aussi dépendant on va le
dire comme ça alors il ya les questions
énergétiques
enfin il ya quand même si les questions
alimentaires et le confinement aussi
comme dans le territoire hexagonal
il a montré une nouvelle pratique de la
consommation
consommer local
on sert comporter de manière
complètement différente sur ces sujets
là aussi de l'argent du plan de relance
sera mis pour accélération de
transformation agricole
je vais l'occasion peut-être d'y revenir
en tout cas je ne veux pas être être
autrement
je répondre à vos questions sur les
outils de relance la partie européen du
plan de relance la question des comme
dans le plan de relance ingénieurs
pâques tous ces sujets me sont
complètement identifiée mais peut-être
que je les garde pour pour les changes
bon et puis ensuite il ya les sujets
connexes mais évidemment qui s'invite
largement dans l'agenda du ministre est
donc aussi de la délégation d outre-mer
six mois à ou dino globalement un tiers
de mon temps sur la nouvelle calédonie
processus institutionnel que vous
connaissez accords matignon oudinot 88
accords de nouméa 98 on arrive à la fin
du podium
c'est à dire en clair on a l'accord de
nouméa il va quelques manières que ce
soit touché à sa fin puisque il avait
prévu effectivement un système de deux
référendums en crémaillère qui
permettait de respecter un engagement
pris par la france devant les nations
unies d'un processus d'autodétermination
et de reconnaissance d'un peuple
autochtone est évidemment ce système à
trois référendums nous amène petit à
petit pas loin du troisième évidemment
quand on n'est pas loin de la fin de
quelque chose ça pose beaucoup de
questions sur les suite ça veut donc
dire que qu'il nie qu'il y ait un
référendum que la réponse soit oui que
le soin non ou qu'il n'y ait pas
troisième référendum parce qu'après tout
c'est au congrès le 2 mai qu'elle ait
décidé quoi qu'il arrive
l'accord de nouméa touche à sa fin et
donc quoi qu'il arrive il faudra bien
imaginer un nouvel accord un nouvel
accord soit parce que l'indépendance
l'emportera via un accord de transition
soit parce que la nouvelle clinique
reste dans la france formé un accord
pour imaginer la suite de l'histoire
surface qui a pas de troisième
référendum il faudra bien un accord
aussi parce que l'accord de nouméa est
terminée de façon quoi qu'il arrive là
la génération de parlementaires que vous
est plus ou moins court moyen terme
devra s'intéresser parce qu'on a
largement interroger la constitution et
les lois organiques successives sur la
question calédoniennes vous serez d'une
manière amené à vous intéresser et à
travailler sur la question de la
nouvelle qu'elle était une manière ou
d'une autre et donc évidemment cela me
revient sous l'autorité du premier
ministre évidemment et du présent de la
république
si je pourrai revendre à vos questions
l'actualité de l'île du sud jean
françois longeot il ya le présent non
joués a imposé une question de prémy sur
ce sujet n'est jamais qu'un épisode
lourd grave important mais d'un
processus institutionnel lui-même
beaucoup plus globale et non moins
complexe d'autres sujets sains vite mais
je vais me taire des sujets qui me
tiennent à coeur la question de l'eau
aux antilles est pas qu aux antilles à
mayotte mais les sources évidemment de
du problème ne sont pas forcément les
mêmes les questions régaliennes
évidemment la question de l'immigration
je veux pas leur cité mayotte et la
guyane comme exemple mais là aussi la
des attentes des élus et des
parlementaires sont fortes
là encore toute récente ancien maire de
cayenne me poser une question au
gouvernement sur ce sujet il ya il ya
peu de temps autant de sujets évidemment
sur lequel on est mobilisé
même si la crise que vivent bien là
aussi modifier le plan de charge le plan
de bataille des foires sécurité
intérieure de l'ensemble du personnel de
l'état et pour cause personne ne
comprendrait que l'on suivra aussi trop
de lièvres à la fois ci tout est
important c'est que rien ne le voilà
monsieur le président de manière
liminaire ce que je pouvais vous dis
merci monsieur le ministre d'avoir
planté le décor si je puis ainsi dire et
je vous propose de procéder par séries
de cinq questions pour qui une dynamique
sinon ça risque d'enliser et puis je
pense que
l'on est loin de moi cette idée c'est le
munichois né votre tonicité dans le
débat commencé à donner la parole à
madame lopez pour la première question
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre merci merci pour toutes les
informations que vous nous avez
communiqué alors je ne peux pas vous
parler du covin et de la pandémie parce
que je crois que on lan est un peu
saturé parce qu'on l'entend que cela
partout je vais vous parler de l'avenir
qui vous concerne la mer puisqu'il
semblerait d'ailleurs la pandémie l'a
prouvé que la mer était quelque chose
était notre avenir et j'aurais aimé
savoir où on en est de la création de
hub en outre mer avec des infos de hub
avec des infrastructures sanitaires
militaire construction réparation navale
qu'en est-il aussi de notre volonté de
promouvoir des offres de formation
maritime régionale est la dernière
question sera quelles actions menez-vous
pour faciliter la venue des jeunes à
métropole pour se former aux métiers de
la mer à moins qu'il y ait des écoles
d'enseignement de la mer en outre mer je
vous remercie
merci madame jasmin mais bonjour à tous
bonjour monsieur ministres vont amener à
vous tous alors je ne sais pas vous
m'entendez vue parfaitement d'accord et
un retour oui alors félicité d'une part
les antillais est particulièrement on
est quoi l'opn insu et indépendamment
les chiffres de la commune de chez nous
dans la mesure où pour le moment il n'y
a pas toutes les restrictions que nous
connaissons ici à paris et dans
l'hexagone donc c'est grâce aux efforts
conjugués des uns et des autres des élus
et c'est vrai que ce soit au niveau de
la préfecture la rs en fait il ya eu des
efforts qui ont été demandés avec
l'accord de la plupart des élus et les
résultats sont là donc je dois féliciter
quand même tout le monde l'a concernant
le plan de relance je vais pas revenir
sur ce qui a été dit
il ya quelques jours au sein du comité
du comité qui s'est réuni avec la
préfecture
donc il ya quand même les inquiétudes
concernant monsieur ministre les
travailleurs indépendants et c'est pour
le moment une situation critique qui va
arriver dans la mesure où beaucoup de
petits très petites entreprises auront
des difficultés parce qu'il n'y a pas la
même dynamique même si le tourisme a
repris pendant sept pays a lancé vrai on
aura un certain nombre de difficultés et
parce qu'il ya également les entreprises
par contre qu'ils ont pu faire le prêt
garanti par l'état qui auront également
des difficultés parce que la relance ne
s'est pas encore vraiment fait dans la
dynamique de la consommation pour
revenir sur les risques naturels un jury
particulièrement le plan séisme antilles
j'ai été une des co rapporteur pour la
mission qui a été effectuée par le
scénar 2018
pour le premier volet concernant les
risques naturels majeurs et nous avons
fait un certain nombre de
recommandations et monsieur le président
de la république avait proposé mais bien
avant en suite au suite aux difficultés
des risques li na et maria de faire une
proposition de loi vous l'avez évoqué
tout à l'heure il y a des dents les
recommandations que nous avons fait un
certain nombre de situations qui serait
bon de mettre en évidence et de résoudre
assez rapidement notamment l'utilisation
des fonds barnier
parce que dans une recommandation nous
avons évidemment suite aux différentes
auditions que nous avions fait le
déplacement sur le terrain nous avons
constaté que les collectivités avaient
beaucoup de mal à utiliser ces fonds
barnier
donc là on nous avons demandé qu'il y
ait une révision des modalités
ce qui n'est toujours pas fait et vous
savez très bien que beaucoup de
collectivités en outre mer ont des
difficultés financières il faudrait
peut-être qu'on trouve les voies et les
moyens pour en tout cas faciliter
l'accès à ces fonds qui sont là et que
les collectivités ne peuvent pas
utiliser pour avancer dans les
différents travaux en tout cas donc tout
ce qui est nécessaire à mettre en oeuvre
pour
ue et la situation vous avez évoqué
également le trait de côte
mais c'est vrai que l'érosion du trait
de côte nous concerne beaucoup concerne
également la voix nous parce que la
ville de petit bout en train de déplacer
une partie de sa population
parce que nous avons été sur place nous
avons également vu mais c'est une
réalité il est urgent de prendre des
mesures
donc par petits bouts il ya d'autres
communes également nous voyons à
sainte-anne comment la mère arrive donc
il ya des mesures urgentes à prendre et
en même temps il ya une certaine
réticence donc j'ai reçues il y a
vingt-quatre heures à peu près le
rapport de 2,2 du délégué
interministériel que je n'ai pas encore
vraiment pu lire id quantique et je
crois qu'il est une fable à prendre la
mesure de cette urgence parce qu'on
parle de réchauffement mais nous les
vivons au quotidien et déjà donc il est
urgent de mettre en oeuvre et de tenter
de finir en tout cas ce qu'il faut pour
que ces préconisations et ses
recommandations en tout cas les plus
importantes soient mises en évidence
sont en tout cas n'ont pas d'avenir
l'évidence mais soit facilité pour
permettre aux uns et aux autres de les
réaliser
la dernière chose vous dans le temps
alors il ya eu la loi la proposition de
loi 3d ensuite cap d je voulais savoir
ce que vous entendez quelle est la
définition que vous donnez à la dé
complexification parce que là vous avez
ajouté
et pour le moment je n'ai pas une
véritable compréhension de ce qui est
attendu avec 7 des complexification et
puis à la question de l'eau c'est une
urgence c'est où on voit tout
particulièrement il y a certes un
certain nombre d'avancées
avec l'ensemble des collectivités qui
veulent aller vers syndicat unique mais
il ya encore un certain nombre de
divergences sur certains points précis
mais je tiens à souligner ici dans son
sein de cette réunion que pratiquement
tous les opci la région et le
département sont d'accord pour un
syndicat unique
seulement il ya un certain nombre de
d'éléments qui freine les oeufs et les
autres sont en tout cas certains
concernant les dettes de certaines
certains opci et il ya une certaine
transparence une café à apporter donc le
mais il ya une volonté réelle au niveau
de notre département tout cas de faire
avancer ce dossier et c'est sur les
dommages que qui est pas dans le
dispositif de droit commun il ya la
possibilité simplement parce qu'il y
aurait certainement de divergences
d'opinion pour certains points mais pas
sûr et égalité voilà est la dernière
chose monsieur le ministre je sais
action votre attention sur aussi
l'emploi l'emploi des jeunes et des
moins jeunes mais surtout les procédures
de dépôt de propositions des dépenses
quand on voit d'où particulièrement
parce que beaucoup de deux postes qui
sont à pourvoir ne sont pas mis à dispo
l'information n'est pas transparente
n'est pas mis à la disposition de la
population suicide de pôle emploi
j'ai cité également des services de
l'état qui font des recrutements et ses
recrutements des services de l'état se
font dans notre l'opacité en tout cas
parce que jamais au moment où on parle
de nos jeunes qui viennent dans
l'hexagone faire des études au cas pour
la plupart et bien l'éthique les
diplômes sont obtenus et ont les mêmes
valeurs pour les ultramarins et pour les
hexagonaux et on voit très bien que dans
la façon de procéder pour des
recrutements et bien on ne donne pas
pour les diplômes à diplôme égal à
compétences égales les hexagonaux sont
quelquefois on aura coûté directement
depuis l'hexagone à longueuil quelle
méconnaissance de ces postes-là de leur
disponibilité sur nos territoires
donc je voudrais qu'il y ait une
certaine transparence désormais sur
cette possibilité de recruter et que nos
jeunes diplômés mais aussi les moins
jeunes toutes les personnes en tout cas
qui sont capacité de pouvoir occuper
certains postes à responsabilités et
l'impossibilité de le faire en toute
transparence qui est exigé et qui est
dans le noir dans le droit commun et pas
par des circuits qui sont opaques et pas
forcément transparent pour tout le monde
voilà je m'arrêterai là monsieur le
ministre
merci monsieur président de m'avoir
merci
merci faire victoire nous partons
maintenant la réunion mais ces
événements oui bonjour avec le béninois
stéphane longeot à 12 bonne année je
vais être bref parce qu on n ont donc
chacun aura ta question je vais pour me
concentrer sur la question logement
sortir de la sinistrose d'engendrer
politis 9 m2 de logements en janvier
2019 le camp logement outre-mer et et il
s'est décliné à la réunion qu'on appelle
le pommeau dur de savoir aujourd'hui
depuis janvier 2019 un bilan ce qui a
été fait et qui va être fait dans les
années futures
voilà je resterai des justes dans ce
secteur logement que nous avons toutes
les questions lui demande les deux
surfaces merci de votre réponse
merci beaucoup monsieur théophile oui
bonjour à tous heureux jour subissons
nous avaient battus au gel de décision
d'aller voir la conscience concernant
l'origine des opérations de lotois
nommément selon cette décision une une
production qui n'ouvriraient plus de 90%
des besoins de la consommation locale ne
pourraient plus bénéficier de cette
exonération la commission européenne à
oreille ou et vue d'aborder un certain
nombre d'exceptions sans que cela ne
soit de nature à nous rassurer nous et
selon ren de rodome
35 cents et 2 milliards d'euros de
production locale les indices qui dans
les normes sont trop jeunes ils ont une
dernière question une innovation moi
monsieur lentilles que 80 de la dernière
loi relative à l'organisation et à la
transformation du système de santé
équipe très moyenne la remise rapport au
parlement sur les respectives du
phénomène 6 vous le savez les étudiants
de la faculté de médecine des antilles
et la guyane sont actuellement obligés
de se rendre dans l'hexagone
une fois leur troisième année a terminé
ce qui pose un certain nombre de
difficultés ou les étudiants eux mêmes
bien sûr est lourd un outil qui doit
ensuite en juin 2000 m
il ne l'est toujours omar avez vous vu
que j'ai pas mal de fois a rappelé le
ministre concerné 2010 précisément donc
avez vous eu
avez vous des informations à nous donner
à lissieu s'entraîner
merci et nous terminons cette première
série d'orateurs avec le président
passion si il est avec nous je ne la
perçois pas l'écran vous avez la parole
bonjour bonjour monsieur le ministre
bonjour à tous les participants un grand
bonjour de la guyane qui suit
actuellement mon propos pompera
essentiellement sur les quorums le
fameux contrat d'accompagnement
financier mais je ne peux m'empêcher a
même été entre les ministres sur des
questions de tact ua lité lieu
très criante en guyane 1ère qui est
première question sur l'actualité c'est
bien sûr le traitement de la cour vide
il en a parlé mais la situation allant
s'empirant en guyane dans tout le monde
redoute et annonce déjà un certain
nombre de mesures restrictives
qu'est ce qu'il en est et lui également
mon l'acquisition du carnaval avec les
mesures qui qui sont prises les mesures
dissuasives même quelquefois très
sensible qui ont soulevé une polémique
en guyane comme l'envoi de chiens contre
les carnavaliers il ya également une
question très criante ennuyant c'est la
question du traitement de l'immigration
clandestine avec l'arrivée sur le
territoire de la guyane de cubains qui
ont été relâchés sur le territoire d'une
commune par les forces armées ça aussi
c'est un suspect très important et
troisième question d'actualité ayant
cessé la réforme du code minier monde
les miniers attendaient l'arrivée de la
ministre pour savoir ce qu'il en était
en termes d'exploitation aurifère
comme vous le savez elles les son voyage
au tout dernier moment
et là c'est quand même une situation un
petit peu d'enjeu ça c'est propre petite
question que je ne pouvais ne pas poser
au
au ministre les ma question essentielle
pour respectivement sur le grand bain on
a beaucoup parlé de la relance mais
concernant surtout et les entreprises
faut quand même pas oublier les
collectivités dit on le sait chez nous
ils sont les fers de lance de la relance
la mesure prise en loi de finances a été
saluée à l'unanimité par tous les
parlementaires tous les sénateurs mais
maintenant nous allons rentrer dans le
vif du sujet qu'est ce qu'il en est et
ce que les 30 millions seront utilisés
ils sont prévues pour trois ans mais
quand on connaît le monde par des
déficits de de certaines collectivités
ce que ce montant sera suffisant et ce
qui sera revu et corrigé
je ne voudrais pas parler uniquement de
6,2 de cette participation financière de
l'es22 de l'état parce que ce n'est
qu'un aspect de ces contrats
d'accompagnement il ya également le
volontariat et surtout l'amélioration de
la gestion des collectivités qui est
visuel traverse et d'accompagnement aux
financiers le fait de placer en
permanence qu'elle lève des niveaux de
ces collectivités s mesure de tutelle
comme certains déjà dénoncé cette
disposition est ce que justement les
revendications en termes de de conduire
et à l'amélioration des ressources des
collectivités sera suspendu et dans
cette période parce que comme on le sait
quand même il ya toujours embêtant de
péréquation et le rattrapage effet
souhaité cinq ans j'ai demandé qu'il
soit revu dans un espace plus réduit est
ce qu'on pourra revenir sur ces
commandes dispositions qui permettront
aux collectivités locales d'outre-mer
locaux une meilleure assise financière
il a livré également
leur gestion voilà le souhait me dit
j'espère j'ai été trop loin
merci donc nous avons achevé la première
série les cinq orateurs je vais
maintenant laisser un peu de temps
monsieur le ministre évidemment de vous
répondre
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
merci mesdames et mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs pour man pour vos
questions alors je prends mon mon peigne
et je je je remonte tout cela d'abord
sur la stratégie maritime
bon là évidemment c'est un des sujets le
sigle du plan de relance
on va se parler assez directement les ya
pas une situation qui ne correspond pas
des territoires très différenciée je
pense que à la réunion on a une
organisation
g j'ai du mal à parler désormais de
clusters puisque le mot et est
malheureusement un peu connoté
souterrain sanitaires enfin il y avait
quand même la préfiguration d'une offre
consolidé d'acteurs de la mer va dire ça
comme ça
kiki quand même tout à fait robuste à la
réunion qui s'appuie autant sur les
infrastructures que sur les métiers
évidemment de la pêche
on a également le monde de la recherche
sur les fonds sous-marins avec en plus
des partenariats qui sont importants bon
il ya des choses qui vont être envoyés
au fond noir
l'ancienne miss des outre-mer devenu
ministre de la mer
justement est en train de mener et c'est
avec elle que évidemment vous pourrez
avancer sur ces stratégies de deux hubs
et notamment évidemment sur les sur les
questions portuaire pareil sur les
filières de formation là on a aussi des
choses qui tiennent à la qui tiennent
évidemment la route en lien avec avec
des sites normands ou aux bretons sur
les stratégies maritime parce
qu'évidemment il ya eu un partage entre
annick girardin et moi cela va sans dire
je moi je suis attentif à ce qu'on ait
quand même des des choses qui se parlent
entre les trois océans voyage était à
saint martin l'autre jour où j'ai reçu
un briefing sur la tacc requins que nous
avons malheureusement connu juste avant
les fêtes où malheureusement une
personne à
a perdu la vie on sait très bien qu'à la
réunion on a désormais un recul avec une
communauté scientifique immobilisée sur
ces sujets et qui préconise des choses
on voit très très bien que en polynésie
française
on a en résidence des chercheurs qui
travaillent sur cette biodiversité là et
qu'ils cherchent justement à trouver des
moyens différencier de piste est
typiquement les avocats qui sont des
requins prédateurs moi je veux bien on a
dans chaque territoire des gens qui font
des choses et c'est quand même encore
redoutablement cloisonné et ça il faut
qu'on arrive à le décloisonnement et le
meilleur moyen que je puisse faire
avancer les choses
c'est ce plant passer des commandes est
typiquement sur le requin je vous dis je
n'ai jamais dit publiquement
j'ai demandé à ce qu'on réfléchisse à
non pas une stratégie aucun parce qu on
n en existe déjà
je regarde massimo nava s'est beaucoup
mobilisée sur ces sujets dans son
territoire et compris lorsqu'elle
présidait le conseil départemental
mais on doit pouvoir avoir des réponses
plus globale sur les questions sur les
questions maritimes et quand on dit la
mère cette fois tout dire et rien dire
l'univers est très vaste et la mère du
président artano entre saint pierre et
miquelon présente des indes et des
enjeux et des intérêts qui ne sont pas
évidemment les mêmes que lorsqu'on est
en polynésie française 3 donc ça va
falloir évidemment différencier tout
tout seul à même la sénatrice jasmin
alors travailleurs indépendants il faut
nous faire remonter les cas les cas
pratiques parce que on a fait très
attention à ce qu' ils soient éligibles
au pge au fonds de soutien
quand ils ont un peu de ça va même
quelques salariés évidemment ils ont ils
sont éligibles au chômage partiel donc
sur la partie solidarité et gestion de
l'urgence du moment le compte y est
après fallait raisonner par par secteur
je ne sais pas la taille de l'entreprise
qui va faire les choses voyez on a fait
un choix
j'ai fait un choix et ça a été validée 2
quand même de faire très très attention
au secteur du btp
et pour cause en milieu insulaire c'est
souvent quand même le tourisme et le btp
qui ne sont pas les seuls secteurs
économiques mais enfin ils tiennent
quand même une large partie du de
l'économie surtout du l'emploi que l'on
peut connaître sur les différents
territoires qui dit btp 10 commandes
publiques par qui dit commande publique
dit commande publique de l'état
les commandes publiques des
collectivités territoriales
enfin on peut retourner dans tous les
sens moi c'est quand même après y'a
quand même le marché des particuliers
m'enfin c'est pas le marché des
particuliers qui va faire redémarrer le
btp il faut que le l'acheteur public ça
je les dis avec beaucoup de force en
martinique notamment va réunir
l'ensemble du monde économique
il faut quand marty il faut que dans les
territoires et les les acheteurs publics
aussi soient très vigilants à la manière
dont ils vont rédiger les cahiers des
charges
comment ils vont attribuer les marchés
quelle place on donne aux petits
indépendants aux petites structures dans
la commande publique
moi si j'ai souhaité quand j'étais
ministre en charge des collectivités
territoriales edouard philippe avait
validé le principe de sentir cette
fameuse des sites exceptionnels là
disent ils salamin des préfets dans un
dialogue opérationnel avec les élus
quelle que soit la collectivité
territoriale soit on fait des grosses
sommes pour des gros chantiers
ça profite à certains réseaux
d'entrepreneurs
soit on est sur une stratégie de petits
travaux dans les communes rurales
fonctionne d'ailleurs très très bien les
petits travaux d'entretien etc
ça nous permettent d'intéresser
directement réseaux économiques de
proximité mais on peut pas dire qu'il
faut donner beaucoup de décentralisation
et beaucoup de confiance aux territoires
c'est pas le ministre qui peut choisir
les entreprises qui vont travailler et
ça je ne ferai pas ça
donc par définition on met de l'argent
on met de l'argent sur plan séisme
antilles on met l'argent sur les réseaux
l'adie pour l'eau je viendrai tout à
l'heure les réseaux d'eau par définition
sont des travaux qui peuvent être
effectués par par des famines
entreprises des regroupements
d'entreprises et ça évidemment il faut
le moniteur et et si cette boule ou de
l'état donc le gouvernement et le
parlement que de débloquer des sommes
pour les différents territoires
ensuite évidemment dans une école dans
une notion très décentralisé de tout
cela c'est évidemment quand même aux
élus locaux de veiller à ce que tout le
monde soit intéressé fonds barnier vous
avez raison des mesures déjà
d'assouplissement tu été prises dans les
différentes lois de finances je crois
qu'avec le sénateur du nord marchand
avait déjà
procéder à quelques amendements la
matière pour permettre à des
particuliers d'utiliser plus facilement
le fonds barnier
en fait il ya encore deux sujets qui
sont lourds nous les vues en martinique
récemment il ya l'utilisation du fonds
barnier en tant que telle est d'ailleurs
lié à l'utilisation préventive isation
curative en quelques heures
il faut déjà traité un risque la maison
n'est déjà plus du tout habité et on est
déjà dans la logique on arrive après
puis la logique on arrive à nanterre que
on voit bien qu'on a des glissements de
terrain importants et donc il va falloir
sécuriser toute une zone c'est pas tout
à fait la même manière de s'en servir et
cantona en curatif c'est la coordination
entre le fonds barnier
les assureurs et leur somme le fonds de
solidarité outre-mer qui est un fonds
qui qui dépend de mon ministère je suis
très direct là aussi moi je suis très
très attentif à la solidarité nationale
je veux pas non plus qu'on se substitue
aux assureurs si si nos concitoyens si
les collectivités locales si l'état paye
des polices d'assurance c'est aussi un
moment donné pour que quand même les
assureurs fassent leur travail
je ne dis pas qu'ils ne le font pas et
je trouve que les brocarts parfois trop
vite mais il faut bien faire attention à
qui fait quoi donc le fonds barnier il
faut bien aussi leur orienté sur ce qui
est important ce que je voyais la
tentation c'est de mettre le fonds
barnier à toutes les sauces parce qu'il
est il et c'est un fonds qui est
populaire utile efficace mais il faut
faire aussi attention à la manière dont
s'organise
mais là aussi si on travaille sur les
risques naturels outre mer on pourra pas
travailler sur ce sujet sera évidemment
parler du fond barnier
lowell loupe sujet
kim est connu puisque j'ai commencé à
travailler sur ce dossier comme
secrétaire d'état à l'écologie puis
ensuite que ministre en charge des
collectivités territoriales puis
maintenant de votre mère bon moi
j'entends ce que vous dites mais je vous
rejoins
je vais redire publiquement pour la
délégation aux outremers ce que j'ai dit
aux parlementaires et aux élus de la
guadeloupe et je regarde dominique
théophile lorsque je me suis déplacé
pour la pour la saint sylvestre la loi
n'est pas obligatoire pour arriver à
créer une structure unique mais pour
qu'il y ait une structure unique
il faut que tout le monde soit d'accord
tout le monde c'est tout le monde sait
pas tout le monde moi un opci faut pas
vous dire mieux milieu insulaire par
définition l'interdépendance des réseaux
d'eau va c'est une évidence mais donc
l'unicité du syndicat ces deux meilleurs
moyens de mener des opérations
d'investissement qui vont bien pour
l'avenir
il ya des doutes sur les questions de
reprise de dettes je peux le comprendre
mais quoi qu'il arrive la dissolution du
ciac elle amènera tout fait ce mois un
retour de la compétence aux pc tout
simplement parce que je regarde les
sénateurs qui ne sont pas guadeloupéens
on sait très bien que ce sont les opci
qui sont compétents en matière d'eau et
que d'ailleurs après ils peuvent le
délégué un syndicat mais il n'en demeure
pas mois que l'assemblée délibérante qui
est légitime pour traiter des questions
d'eau c'est l'assemblée délibérante de
le pci en guadeloupe comme ailleurs donc
il n'y a pas de raison de deux 2 de
regarder les choses différemment
d'autres
moi mon objectif est assez simple c'est
que les guadeloupéennes et les
guadeloupéens et de l'eau et j'ai le
sentiment qu'on a déjà laissé beaucoup
de temps parfois quand on est ministre
on arrive on découvre un dossier on n'a
pas forcément l'intériorité
ça fait trois ans et demi qui unissent
avait trois ans et demi qu'on en parle
alors soit on dit que c'est important et
on avance sont dit que c'est moins
important parce que les échéances
électorales au mois de juin mais ça
c'est pas mon problème
moi je vous dis comme je le pense je ne
veux pas rentrer là dedans et je salue
mois les efforts je les dis publiquement
les efforts qui ont été faits dans le
passé je sais que victorin lurel en tant
que ministre en tant que président de
conseil régional
avait fait avancer les choses la
présence du conseil départemental et
mobiliser aussi sur sur ce sujet je n'ai
pas pu discuter avec le président avait
chez lui ce lors de ma dernière visite
j'espère pouvoir le faire bientôt mais
je souhaite vraiment qu'on avance sur
sur ces questions de l'eau et urgences
mille fois plus chez pathé du si on a un
accord de tous les opci pour faire une
structure unique balle en guadeloupe
comme ailleurs n'est pas besoin d'une
loi pour faire un syndicat unique avec
tous les plaisirs
s'il manqua de pci pour des questions
qui font des questions légitimes telles
qu'elles sont posés d'ailleurs par le
président de cette pci parce qu'il ne le
fait pas pour de mauvaises raisons
belle initiative du sénateur théophile
ici présents de déposer cette
proposition de loi est une proposition à
qui méritera en tout cas d'être discutés
dans l'hémicycle parce qu'elle viendra
quand même répondre à des questions qui
sont soulevées par nos concitoyens par
là je parle monopolisé le sujet sur la
question de l'ong loupe on aura
l'occasion de le refaire moi je suis je
suis têtu sureau aucune aucun moyen pour
y arriver je veux juste qu'on ne soit
pas dans le sac ulcos et qu'on avance
s'agit j'y crois beaucoup
on a mis beaucoup d'argent sur le plan
odom on remet beaucoup d'argent avec le
plan de relance
d'aucuns diraient que c'est pas assez
c'est peut-être pas assez enfin moi qui
suis aussi un peu élu local sur les
bords je crois qu'on est tous attachés
dans cette maison qu'elle sénat un
principe qui est loupé l'eau en tout cas
j'ai toujours entendu ça j'ai en tout
cas j'ai jamais entendu un sénateur qui
disait qu'il fallait recentraliser l'eau
j'ai jamais entendu un sénateur dire qu'
il fallait revoir la notion de l'eau
pelo et qui avait quand même un modèle
auquel on est tous attachés dans cette
maison me semble-t-il
jusqu'à preuve du contraire et bah faut
qu'on garde loupé l'eau en guadeloupe il
se trouve que le contribuable paye l'eau
est comme le l'usager paye non seulement
sa facture d'eau meir paye en plus par
ses impôts à ce que l'état c'est nous
tous
donc ça c'est bien pour les gestions
d'urgence pour le rattrapage mais
évidemment ça pourra pas être un modèle
où l'état supporte tous les travaux de
réseaux d'eau en gaudeloupe pendant des
années donc moi je je suis attentif à
pas laisser ça à mes successeurs
parce que ça fait trop longtemps que ça
dure et je veux quand même qu'on avance
après peut-être que je m'y prends mal
peut-être que je fais pas bien les
choses je veux bien tout entendre en
tout cas je veux
je veux que ça avance odeurs je ne dis
pas que vous ayez 10 à spa j'ai bien
entendu
peut-être qu'à travers vous je
m'adressais à d'autres en fait l'heure
je crois que j'en suis sûr je crois qu'à
travers vous je jette en train de
s'adresser à d'autres
monsieur le sénateur des deux mondes sur
le logement
bon je reviens pas sur le volet
financier no mercy la caractère bref
delà de la question je vais essayer
d'être aussi efficace que vous les
questions financières sur le logement en
a beaucoup parlé pendant la loi de
finances c'est la question de la lb eu
on recommence pas sur les sous
consommation etc
d'autant plus que là on le voit bien sur
l'année 2020 on a un niveau de
consommation qui est tout à fait
convenable c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire avec des revendications de crédit
des projets se sont quand même débloqué
le fait aussi de ne pas avoir confiné
comme partout de ne pas avoir fait la
gestion du cas vite comme partout je le
dis pour les sénateurs hexagonaux fait
aussi qu'on a des effets qui ne sont pas
tout à fait à regarder de la même
manière et pour cause il n'y a pas eu
les mêmes mesures de freinage donc ça a
permis quand même d'avancé sur sur les
sujets non si je devais retenir 3 3 3
sujet sur lequel il faut continuer
d'avancer sur le logement
trois sujets sur lequel on va pas se
raconter d'histoires ils sont parfois
bien souvent les sources du retard en
investissement plus que des questions de
manque d'argent
le premier c'est inévitable de nouveau
ces allégations et l'ingéniérie
bon voilà ça a été largement traitée je
ne m'attarde pas on met des moyens dans
le cadre du plan de relance sur
l'ingénierie territoriale lors des
collectivités 30 millions d'euros de
mandat donné à l'afd qui va permettre de
renforcer justement les moyens des
différentes collectivités
quelle est la question de la gouvernance
j'ai pu me rendre compte à la réunion à
votre département
on a quand même parfois des problèmes
d'alignement planète région département
pci et bailleurs sociaux et c'est pas
une critique un peu plus une fois j'ai
dit ça évidemment vous montrer du doigt
les élus locaux
non je trop sénateurs pour faire
attention à ça donc je
je dis juste que le nom il ya des
problèmes de gouvernance ou simplement
mais je pense qu'il faut il faut le dire
et le troisième on est en train de le
régler notamment les travaux de serge
letchimy ont permis de le faire mais
c'est la question bien sûr du foncier
soit du foncier par les problèmes
d'indivision sur les volets succession
etc
des choses ont été faites ça produit des
effets soient du foncier parce que on
revient aux risques naturels ou la
logique d'occupation des sols ou aux
outils et vous avez vu dans le plf quant
à mayotte et en guyane
bah on remet des moyens pour les eps qui
sont des établissements publics fonciers
qui évidemment produisent des eaux des
outils pour faire des choses qui nous
permettent d'avancer donc gouvernance
ingéniérie foncier avec un peu d'argent
en plus entre nous j'ai bon espoir que
ça produit des effets ou après faut
évidemment se déployer sur la fête ses
18 millions d'euros en plus qu'on met
sur la élevé cette année
or les crédits par ailleurs du plan de
relance sur un certain nombre de sujets
donc entre sa la rénove on devrait quand
même arriver à sortir quelque chose à
mon avis pour l'année 2000 21 /
le sénateur théophile à leur octroi de
mer commission européenne les choux sont
encore en cours on a on a des échanges
opérationnels avec avec avec la
commission sur ce sujet ça peut faire
l'objet d'ailleurs là aussi de
discussion des changes haddock en la
matière nous on attend une décision du
conseil
globalement avant la fin du mois de juin
dans tout ça va se jouer dans le cadre
de ce semestre la commission devrait
prendre la parole
une des choses aux alentours du mois de
février et en fonction de ce qu'il
sortira tous savourent a donné lieu à
une transposition en droit français avec
le plf 2022
ça c'est pour répondre à votre question
sur le calendrier de cette affaire on ne
refuse pas tous les bouger comme vous le
savez parce qu'il ya des propositions
d'évolution dans le cadre de l'e3 mère
qui sont des choses qui sont parfois
attendu pense notamment parfois au aux
productions dites locales c'est quand
même très compliqué parfois expliqué qu'
on fait peser de l'autre trois maires
qui est une barrière douanière de
protection sur des biens qui ont été
produits sur les territoires concernés
appliquez une barrière douanière à un
produit endogène c'est pas quand même
tout à fait spontané en termes
d'explication
moi je vous dis comme je le pense je
redis à chaque fois ce que le président
la république avait dit lors du grand
débat
si à une volonté des territoires
d'avancé sur une réforme de l'octroi de
mer le gouvernement sera la disposition
des élus qui voudront avancer sur ce
sujet à chaque fois j'ai un succès
limité quand même quand je dis ça et je
comprends parce que derrière ça pose des
questions d'organisation du marché de
l'offre et la demande
ça renvoie aux questions évidemment de
vie chère par ailleurs on sait bien et
ça on voit surtout la question des
recettes des collectivités territoriales
etc et pas un petit sujet donc donc
voilà mois sur l'autre en mer je suis
vigilant en tout cas on tiendra au
courant l'ensemble des parlementaires
ultramarins des différents niveaux de
discussions que nous avons avec avec la
commission européenne
le rapport qui avait été commandée sur
l'avenir et les perspectives positives à
donner sur la faculté de médecine aux
antilles a été retardé à cause des ducs
au vide tout simplement et donc
normalement la mission sera déclenchée
avant le mois de mai là aussi je vous
propose de tenir au courant les
parlementaires de martinique et de et de
gaulle ou plus d'ailleurs en effet de
ricochet saint barth est évidemment et
et saint martin de vous tenir au courant
du calendrier qui va être retenu
précisément mon cabinet le fera donc
mais pas de pas de changement de
commandes pour répondre à votre question
nationale tant que tel fils s'il n'y a
pas de changement de pied ou de
changement d'avis c'est juste que le
candidat a ralenti des choses alors
monsieur le président patients à vos
trois petites questions sont enfin vos
quatre petites questions dans sont
absolument pas petit donc elle
mériterait pratiquement un développement
de chacune d'entre elles peuvent in
nouvelles mesures guyane je serai amené
m exprimer enfin en tout cas le préfet
sera amené à s'exprimer dans les heures
qui viennent et je l'appuierai
évidemment ce qui mettra en oeuvre bon
j'essaie de tenir leur équilibre entre
l'activité économique entre piques et
évidemment la protection sanitaire de
nos concitoyens cela va sans dire
le deuxième des choses les dit tout à
l'heure est-ce qu appliquer est-ce qu
appliquer les mêmes mesures de freinage
dans cayenne ou à papaïchton est-ce que
ça a du champ sa réponse est non bon
est-ce que néanmoins on va être obligé
de resserrer le couvre-feu je vous dis
tout de suite la réponse est oui je ne
vois pas comment on peut faire autrement
personne ne le comprendrait
aujourd'hui on a un système différencié
de trois zones trois zones une zone sans
couvre feu une zone avec un couvre feu
qui démarre plutôt en première partie de
soirée on a avancé de quelques heures il
ya maintenant quelques jours et un
couvre-feu qui démarre en nuit profonde
bon je vois bien comment il va falloir
qu'on aille vers désormais tout
simplement 2
un couvre-feu qui démarre en fin d'après
midi début de soirée et un couvre-feu
qui démarrerait ennui profond on va
falloir qu'on organise davantage de
choses comme ça se pose la question du
dimanche sur lequel il me semble qu'il
va falloir prendre des mesures de
freinage si vous voulez pour vous
répondre très directement la question
des taux d'incidence qui ne sont pas
bons mais on a un système sanitaire qui
tient parce que on n'est pas en vain je
regarde même la sénatrice de la gueule
on n'est pas en situation de saturation
mais je le dis l opinion publique et c
est ce qui nous écouteront après coup
n'attendons pas d'avoir des leaders et à
saturer pour prendre les mesures qui
s'imposent
jusqu'à présent c'est pas comme ça qu'on
a fait et c'est parce que dès qu'on a la
courbe qui commence à monter on prend la
courbe dans l'écrasent et comme on est
dans des territoires justement
différenciez-vous on arrive à le faire
et puis pour répondre à votre question
vous avez posées évidemment on va
renforcer les contrôles à la frontière
cela va sans dire parce qu'on a beaucoup
trop de de circulation on pense à la
circulation irrégulière
pardon on a aussi des circulations
régulière de nos concitoyens qui
cherchent à échapper aux mesures de
freinage sur notre territoire et qui
vont et qui vont goûter le carnaval
autorisée du surinam ou du brésil bon
enfin pardon mais la circulation du
virus elle est tout aussi
impressionnante sur ce territoire là et
en plus il ya la question du variant des
autres variantes qui va s'inviter donc
évidemment à faire prendre des mesures à
la frontière
je laisserai le préfet détailler les
choses en lien avec la rs je pense que
tous avaient frappé du coin du bon sens
et qu'il nous faut évidemment arriver à
obtenir l'épidémie pour nous tout
simplement pas être en situation de
recombiner je pense qu'il faut dire les
choses avec vous de simplicité sur des
mesures qui ont durci mais on ne
confirme pas comme on a pu confier la
guyane par deux fois donc je tiens cette
ligne là en revanche évidemment il faut
que tout le monde fasse des efforts
j'aimerais quand même remercier les
restaurateurs parce que je trouve que à
la réunion enfin dans tous les
territoires en cahiers sont ouverts on a
quand même globalement des gens qui sont
responsables qui tiennent les protocoles
sanitaires
je ne vous cache pas que j'ai
sont très claires au préfet de procéder
aussi aux fermetures administratives de
céder ce qui ne montre pas l'exemple
parce que sinon on va pas s'en sortir et
on l'a bien vu sur le 31 décembre sur
lequel on avait durci un peu les choses
comme sur les fêtes et la saison
touristique c'est un peu tôt pour dire
que le que la période touristique n'a
pas eu d'impact sur le volet sanitaire
enfin si on regarde les taux d'incidence
ils sont quand même très bas et sont
toujours en dessous de 30 hier en
martinique il avait même plutôt tendance
à se tasser
ça veut dire que globalement on a pu
tenir une saison touristique sans avoir
un taux d'incidence car démarre mais ça
ça tient qu'à une chose c'est parce que
hôteliers restaurateurs
enfin les professionnels du tourisme
trop compris le risque d'euros
confirmant ou de fermeture de ses
activités était majeure et donc ils ont
tenu les choses là on a un devoir
collectif un pas que moi c'est
évidemment de continuer à rappeler ça
parce que faut pas qu'une mauvaise
routine s'installe et en guyane pardon
c'est ce qu'on a commencé un tout petit
peu à voir non pas de la part des
professionnels au fond croyez que
l'épidémie était derrière nous que
c'était pour les autres c'est exactement
ce qui est en train de se se passer la
réforme du code minier en 30 secondes
si la ministre pompier a annulé sa
visite
c'est eu égard aux mesures qu'on va
annoncer sur le terrain sanitaire donc
elle ne l'a pas annulée pour un problème
de fond pour un problème lié au code
minier pense que la préfecture et
services de l'état et les services de
police et gendarmerie sont largement
mobilisés pour faire respecter les
mesures que nous allons prendre en plus
devoir protéger une visite ministérielle
ne paraissait pas respectueux des
équipes du territoire et la ministre des
de même âge et ben non pas d'annuler sa
visite mme de la décaler est donc
évidemment le programme sera repris en
tant que tel sur les sur les questions
minières
bon là sur les questions aurifère moi je
me suis exprimé de nombreuses fois on
tient la ligne sur les grands projets
non respectueux de l'environnement sur
lequel les garanties nous sommes pas ne
semble pas remplies c'est le cas
désormais emblématique est connue de
montagne d'or s'est pas pour autant qu'à
peine filière aurifère qui s'organise
qui est organisée avec des gens qui
veulent aussi développé des mines
beaucoup plus responsable par rapport à
ce que l'on peut voir dans les pays de
la zone
on a des structures minière qui peuvent
être à taille humaine
on a des gens qui luttent contre le
travail illégal et beaucoup de choses
sur la sur lol la question bris faire
sur lequel il faudra y revenir mais je
ne venais pas le temps de le faire sur
les contrats quorum provient pas sur les
principes je pense que désormais ils
sont connus l'ensemble des
parlementaires
je vous cache pas qu'il faut qu'on
réussisse l'exercice en 2021 méprisant
patients parce que tout ça est observée
est évidemment notre capacité à réussir
l'exercice en 21 nous permettra derrière
de démultiplier cette affaire qu'est ce
que je peux vous dire de nouveau les
sommes vous les connaissez je reviens
pas non ce que je peux vous dire qu'on
n'a jamais dit c'est que trente communes
ont été présélectionnés sur la barre de
sur la base de deux critères le premier
critère c'était qu'il y avait une
saisine de la chambre régionale des
comptes avec une expertise en cours est
la deuxième des choses c'est que le
déficit structurel était impossible à
résorber en seulement deux exercices
avec ce deux critères la crc plus deux
exercices budgétaires compliquées
on a globalement une trente communes qui
pouvait être présélectionnés sur ses
trente communes
on ressort du filtre douze communes de
guadeloupe 6 de martinique 9 de guyane
de mayotte est une de la réunion j'ai
saisi chacun des maires je me concentre
sur les communes parce que je pense que
c'est là où il faut qu'on soit le plus
performant pour arriver à redresser les
choses
je l'avais écrite tous rien
d'obligatoire expérimentation
volontariat ton cas assez mr de faire
acte de candidature et l'idée c'est de
travailler sur dix communes sur ces 30
et de mettre le paquet sur ces dix
communes pour essayer de trouver le bon
système
l'accompagnement la facturation la
transe
je ne commence pas à vous connaissez le
par ailleurs l'exercice je crois que
j'ai oublié j'espère en tout cas
merci monsieur le ministre nous avons
encore si le sénateur sénatrice est
qu'ils sont inscrits on va commencer
tout de suite à mémoire est sur les lits
merci merci monsieur le président merci
monsieur ministre de votre présence
meilleurs voeux puisque nous sommes
encore dans les temps j'ai trois
questions précises la première c'est sur
le la crise du cosy d' et leva rien
c'est ça hein j'ai barré afrique du sud
puisqu'il déshonneur faut l'appeler
variant 501 qui qui a pénétré l'océan
indien et dans les deux départements
français
pour l'instant nous devons montrer de la
vigilance mais ce juriste fait des
dégâts dans est déjà dans l'île
comorienne
- eli le maire de la capitale fomboni
est décernée décédé et la population
mohélienne ce est en train de vivre ces
germes en 7
cette crise si j'en parle c'est que vous
vous le savez des comores à mayotte
c'est très facile d'entrer par la voix
clandestine et c'est ma plus grande
crainte parce que par les voies
régulière les choses ont été bien gérées
avec la mise en place un très peu de
temps d'un centre de dépistage à
l'aéroport de dzaoudzi
mais c'est par la voix de l'immigration
clandestine avec ces populations qui
sont en manque de soin et quand c'est
comme ça dès le premier réflexe c'est
d'aller vers les territoires français du
coin et le celui qui est le plus apporté
c'est mayotte et mais aussi la réunion
n'est pas n'est pas épargné quelles
mesures le gouvernement
peut prendre d'urgence pour vous
protéger les populations française de
l'océan indien à l'occasion de la
première vague
un bâtiment militaire avait été envoyé
pour ravitailler est ce que un bâtiment
militaire pour dissuader
pour lutter plus efficacement contre les
risques de de pénétration irrégulière
n'est pas n'est pas envisageable
deuxième
rires j'ai entendu le professeur
delfraissy dire qu'il fallait le
restreindre les relations entre
l'hexagone et ces deux territoires
j'espère que il n'a pas voulu prendre ça
au premier degré parce qu'au contraire
il faut affermir ses liens et montrer à
nos concitoyens de l'océan indien que
l'état l'état est là et va répondre
à la menace et
présenté par ce virus donc ma deuxième
question c'est sur l'eau vous connaissez
également sur le ministre la
problématique de la crise de l'eau à
mayotte île hier les les restrictions
les restrictions se sont arrêtés parce
que la saison des pluies est venu pour
remplir les retenues mais chaque année
on ne va pas recommencer la même la même
crise et il ya une troisième retenues
collinaires qui est programmée depuis
des années et qui ne voient pas le jour
il faut qu'on se dise les choses vous
vous le savez est un problème de gestion
de le pci l'équipe actuelle depuis juin
prend les choses plutôt par le bon bout
c'est une équipe rigoureuse sérieuse le
président et un ancien maire qui a été
réélu qui est quelqu'un de très sérieux
donc là aussi quelle mesure le
gouvernement entend prendre sans
pénaliser l'équipe actuelle parce que
elle fait plutôt montre de moins de
volonté et les premières décisions qui
ont été prises vont dans le bon sens
mais comment l'état peut accompagner
[Musique]
les élus à surmonter la problématique de
l'eau avec l'équipe actuelle et sans et
ça l'a pénalisé et enfin une troisième
question sur la piste longue
le président macron après plusieurs
tergiversations des présidents
gouvernement précédent est venu en
octobre en octobre 2019 pour acter la la
construction de la piste de
l'allongement de la piste d'aviation
l'enjeu est quand même de taille pour ce
territoire puisque il en va de son
désenclavement
or récemment la semaine dernière des
problèmes environnementaux ont été mis
en avant
si à un projet d'envergure de cette
taille c'est un problème environnemental
bêtise le mrap comme le disent ça se
saurait on ne connaît ses problèmes
environnementaux il y à d'autres
chantiers ailleurs par en comparaison de
cette piste qui sont pharaoniques et
pourtant on a dépassé ce cela use de le
problème environnemental donc est ce que
vous pouvez rassurer les mahorais que
conformément à la promesse du président
de la république est un obstacle les
problèmes environnementaux que je
néglige pas
mais ils doivent trouver des solutions
les mahorais ne sont pas pénalisés par
ce projet très attendu pour désenclaver
et ont contribué au développement de
l'île voilà mes trois questions merci il
nous reste encore huit inscrits pour des
questions dont je vais simplement vous
demandez aimablement de commencer à
tasser un petit peu aux interventions
aimablement pour permettre aux ministres
de pouvoir y répondre et surtout pour
vous permettre à toutes et tous de
pouvoir a interpellé le ministre ce
matin madame petrus
oui je disais donc ma question portera
sur le rsa lors de sa venue fin
septembre 2018 à saint martin le
président de la république avait confié
être favorable à revoir les modalités de
gestion et l'attribution du rsa et des
prestations sociales à ses marques comme
l'a demandé la collectivité donc
l'objectif poursuivi était que le rsa
soit dépensé en partie française et non
en partie hollandaise ni eux envoyés à
l'étranger
la loi de finances pour 2010 9 prévoyez
bien l'expérimentation de nouveaux modes
de délivrance du rsa sous la forme de
titres de paiement à partir du 1er
juillet 2019 en guyane à mayotte et à
saint martin 7 il devait être
matérialisée par une carte de paiement
prépayée permettant une aide d'urgence
démonétisé à l'instant de la carte
cohésion que nous avons eu un système
que nous avons instauré après l'ouragan
herman alors le gouvernement a décidé de
mettre en premier lieu cette
expérimentation à saint martin est un
projet de décret fixant les modalités de
réalisation de l'expérimentation été
transmis au conseil d'état à la fin du
mois de mai 2019 malheureusement le
conseil d'état a considéré que la
démonétisation du rsa ne répondait pas à
l'objectif principal poursuivi par ce
dispositif social qui vise à assurer au
bénéfice et au revenu minimum de
subsistance alors monsieur le ministre
de nous faire le deuil de cette
démonétisation est donc dans ce cas il
resterait la possibilité pour l'état de
confier la compétence normative à la
collectivité de saint-martin
ma question est simple et acceptera-t-il
de nous accompagner rapidement si la
collectivité accepte de se saisir de la
compétence non mathieu
merci madame micheline jacques monsieur
le ministre monsieur le président mes
chers collègues
permettez moi de vous adresser mes voeux
ccja sincères ainsi qu'à ceux qui vous
sont chers
puisse cette nouvelle année nous engager
vers un avenir résignons j'aurais
également une question sur l'éducation
et la formation
l'article 51 de la loi égalité réelle
outre-mer encourage en effet à la
création d'une chaire d'excellence qui a
fait l'objet d'une mission confiée à
ferdinand soucramanien auprès du délégué
interministériel à l'égalité des chances
des français d'outre-mer je suis
consciente d urgence que vous avez eues
à gérer depuis votre nomination
mais il s'agit là de nos enjeux à long
terme qui me semble lui aussi urgents
des compétences et des expertises seront
encore plus nécessaire pour repenser les
autres maires à la sortie de la crise et
vous connaissez le déficit de
connaissance des autres maires pouvez
vous nous indiquer l'état d'avancement
de ce projet le cas échéant merci merci
président gontard oui merci merci
monsieur le président messieurs monsieur
le ministre j'ai d'abord démarré par une
nulle part une petite remarque sur la
question de l'eau loupé l'eau parce que
c'est vrai que ça fait quand même un
petit moment que nous payent ils ne
payent pas que l'eau notamment via les
via les agences de l'eau et notamment
l'office de la biodiversité voilà donc
ce qui n'est pas illogique d'ailleurs
mais est donc justement ça me permettait
d'aborder cette question de la
biodiversité
on a eu le sommet sommet lundi par le
président de la république lui et ses 8
cm
à marseille en septembre 1,6 si les
conditions sont réunies la cop15 sur la
biodiversité en chine fond voient qu'on
est sur une année très forte en terme de
biodiversité et ce qui est plutôt plutôt
une bonne chose on avait pu aborder ce
sujet lors du dernier budget enfin dans
les débats sur le sur le but et et
notamment sur le fait que
l'argent et les financements liés à la
biodiversité dans les territoires
d'outre-mer en fait était difficile à
une lisibilité assez complexe puisqu'il
était inséré par répartis dans
différents dans différents ministères et
donc d'avoir une tête une réflexion pour
que à la fois une meilleure visibilité
et qu'on puisse réellement savoir voilà
qu'est ce qui est défini sur sur termes
de moyens sur la bio sur la biodiversité
à destination des outre-mer et puis
notre une autre question puisque le
président a rappelé qu'on allait entamer
à des travaux sur sur la question du
logement avec mes collègues
victorien lurel et puis micheline
machine jacques donc avec différents on
a on s'est réparti réparti le travail
avec un tout à une question sur l'aspect
du logement social
ils sont avec moi je m'intéressais
particulièrement et vous avez parlé de
la relocalisation de l'agriculture et de
voir comment on pouvait relocaliser et
et avoir une agriculture et une
alimentation plus plus locale et je
pense que sur la question du logement on
peut avoir cette même réflexion sur la
question de de matériaux de construction
et de et de retravailler autour de
l'artisanat local et sur / en fait
imaginer le logement de demain et quand
on réfléchit à 100 s'aperçoit qu'on bute
aussi sur tous ces deux nouvelles formes
d'habitat sur beaucoup de normes de
réglementation et donc voilà bien un
ménage en tout cas un travail à faire là
dessus et donc voilà cours de ces
travaux on aura besoin besoin de vous
pour travailler travailler
merci merci une taille dans cette
seconde série d'orateurs avec madame
guylaine oui merci monsieur le président
alors bonjour ine je reviendrai pas sur
le sujet de l'eau parce que la
martinique nous avons exactement le même
sujet je suis retourné chez moi au
diamant pour dix jours sur dix jours de
coupure de plus de douze heures donc que
j'imagine ce que malheureusement la
population vit aussi au jour le jour
je poserai donc le plus tôt de question
de gérard poggia puisqu'il ne peut pas
être là aujourd'hui il m'a demandé de la
pause et donc c'est ceci la campagne de
vaccination dans les autres mers pose la
question du financement de cette
campagne notamment pour les
collectivités qui ont la compétence en
matière de santé publique comme c'est le
cas de la calédonie ils pensent aussi
pour la polynésie a confirmé à confirmer
avec la nature thani lors du plf en
réponse à des interpellations dans le
cadre parlementaire le ministre a
réitéré l'engagement qu'il avait pris
lors de son déplacement calédonie que
l'état examinait dépenses sanitaires
liés à la crise du crid qu'il pourrait
prendre à sa charge pour soulager ces
collectivités face aux coûts exorbitants
que représente l'aspect sanitaire de
cette crise en plus de l'aspect
économique et social aussi monsieur
ministre confirmez-vous que la campagne
de vaccination serait bien prise
complètement en charge par l'état dans
les collectivités du pacifique
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
vous avez la parole
merci beaucoup de nouveaux joueurs
seront peigne alors allons à mayotte
d'abord variant de 500 qu'est ce qu'on
est en train de faire première chose
déjà en train de mesurer le ms a fait
une campagne de tests aux comores un mot
il y évidemment particulier puisque
c'est là où les craintes sont plus les
plus fortes on l'avait rappelé l agence
régionale de santé de mayotte
sous la direction de l'autorité de la
ministre monique bonnet mener également
une campagne de tests pour voir un peu
l'évolution l'évolution du virus
on va avoir assez rapidement ses
résultats désormais on claire entre
demain et la fin de semaine
en tout cas j'ai bon espoir comme pour
tout le reste évidemment on fera
complètement transparence des conseils
quelque chose évidemment on le dit
l'idée évidemment c'est de prendre des
mesures pour protéger moi j'aime j'aime
et votre force votre formule besoin
d'être précis a dit fallait
effectivement restreindre les liens non
il faut il faut les affirme venir pour
mieux se protéger
je le dis côté de moi j'ai un sénateur
de saint pierre et miquelon qui vit dans
un territoire en septaine peut pas dire
que ça distendu les liens entre la
république l'hexagone et
saint-pierre-et-miquelon mais évidemment
l'insularité permet quand même parfois
de prendre des mesures de protection qui
peut être adaptée à chaque territoire
je veux pas être alarmiste mais je veux
quand même préparer l'opinion publique
parce que c'est mon devoir et et henri
cochet c'est le vôtre évidemment en tout
cas eu la république en disant que si le
virus variant 501,1 devaient circuler
aux comores
évidemment cela nous conduirait à
prendre des mesures de protection encore
plus importante
alors c'est pas à rompre les liens non
prendre des mesures pour nous protéger
collectivement oui vous avez raison de
mon nez sur ce terrain là parce qu'il
faut pas se méprendre
je suis renault a tranché quelles sont
ces mesures de protection
potentiellement déjà certaines ont été
mises en oeuvre dès ce week-end vous le
savez notamment sur les capacités à
tester parfois on a adapté les choses
le test avant le départ mais pas au
retour ou uniquement là il est clair que
on a demandé à ce qu'un certain monde
liaison avec des pays africains
soit suspendu ça me semble évidemment de
bon sens et on va systématiser les tests
on va aussi systématiser les tests
parfois à l'arrivée des comores je dis
juste devant le sénateur connaissent ces
sujets par coeur mais à mayotte
aujourd'hui il faut avoir son test
effectué depuis depuis les comores et
vous présenter le test que vous avez
effectué ce n'est faire offense à
personne que de dire qu'il ya un peu de
fraudes et que donc désormais on va
tester à l'arrivée donc on va commencer
à mettre des choses qui vont être
contraignant parce que forcément ça va
créer un peu d'attentes dfid et cetera
mais on va clairement renforcé la
protection de nos frontières ça jeu on a
commencé à le faire et on va continuer
de le faire non seulement on va le faire
entre mayotte et les pays étrangers donc
aux morts puis bien sûr on va le faire
entre la réunion et mayotte
tout simplement parce que la circulation
du virus capacité à créer des sas qui
font qu'on s'assure évidemment la
circulation virale elle est tenue et
contenus alors évidemment il ya quand
même un droit qu'on si j'ai la
circulation des citoyens français ne
fallait pas de doute là dessus
en revanche on peut quand même l'encadré
c'est ce que nous faisons depuis le
début de cette crise l encadré par la
systématisation des tests antigénique
no6 pcr donc ça va aussi poser des
questions sur notre capacité à monter
encore plus davantage en chantant en
puissance sur les tests pcr sur ces
territoires notamment à la réunion qui
peut être la base dans lesquels
évidemment on organisait en organiser
jose pour mayotte également et puis des
réflexions sur sur la table évidemment
de mise en précaution sanitaire dans sa
zone de personnes qui peuvent peut-être
effectivement regarder à l'observance
d'une certaine par exemple pour se
mettre de côté pendant quelques jours
histoire d'être testé par deux fois je
le dis d'autant plus tranquillement que
j'ai moi même fait une 14 en nouvelle
calédonie et que j'ai montré l'exemple
dont jeu
je pars du principe que contre tous
l'exemple sénateurs artano j'imagine
lorsqu'il est rentré dans son territoire
pour les fêtes de fin d'année lui-même a
montré l'exemple en respectant tout cas
je le pense
en tout cas je vous assure que les
préfets a reçu consigne vérifier que
j'ai eu la visite des gendarmes pendant
ces modèles comme promis c'est pas moi
qui ai demandé mais en tout cas on
montre tous l'exemple et donc je pense
enfin on va on va déployer sa dans les
heures qui viennent
ce sénateur mais voilà est-ce qu on est
sur quelque chose nous aurons les liens
et non est-ce qu'on en revanche on va
mettre tellement de protection aux
frontières que y aura des restrictions
de circulation potentiel oui mais c'est
pas du tout la même chose et je pense
que tout le monde le comprend on va le
faire mayotte vis-à-vis des autres pays
de la zone
on va le faire entre mayotte et la
réunion et je le dis pour les sénateurs
de la réunion on va aussi contrôler
davantage les allées et les retours
entre la réunion et la métropole
enfin l'hexagone pardonnez moi parce que
là évidemment il faut qu'on soit capable
de tracer de surveiller et les tests pcr
nous permettront le faire d'avoir aussi
des taux de positivité der garde et on
va c'est la stratégie que les préfets
commenceront à déployer enfin genre on
commence par là où j'ai commencé je
termine par l'eau j'ai commencé
l'urgence d'avoir là le résultat des
tests réalisés par le ms à me lit et aux
comores les tests de mémoire sont partis
au kenya à nairobi
pour résultat et nous c'est pour les
tests réalisés par les autorités
sanitaires françaises c'est les équipes
de pasteur qui observent actuellement
les résultats pour la forme complètement
transparent devant le sénat ce matin sur
eux sur ces sujets sur l'eau bon merci
pour ce que vous avez dit c'est une
compétence des collectivités
territoriales la comparaison entre
mayotte et et guadeloupe pour le coup
n'est pas raison parce que en guadeloupe
ont produit suffisamment d'eau potable
on a un problème de distribution et de
réseaux c'est un problème de fuite si je
devais mettre des mots grand public
mayotte on a une démographie très
positive on a des problèmes certes de
réseau wan et des poèmes de production
dire on ne produit pas assez d'eau donc
merci pour la patience des merveilles de
demeurer sur les tours d'eau en france a
produit ses effets et vous l'avez dit
vous-même à partir de demain ou dès
aujourd'hui je crois en tout cas dans
cette fin de semaine on a
on a des cours d'eau qui vont cesser un
rétablissement progressif de les situer
f2 je suis d'accord avec vous moi je
tiens je tiens aussi à rendre hommage au
président phare dean de cette nouvelle
structure
toutes les retours que j'ai du terrain
ou de mon cabinet convergent pour dire
que on a une équipe engagée qui a envie
de faire des choses et il ne s'agit
absolument pas de la pénaliser bien au
contraire
maintenant qu'on a on a cette rencontre
de bonne volonté on va pouvoir
effectivement remettre sur pieds
syndicats moi j'ai donné des
instructions pour qu'on puisse
travailler impacts sur l'eau avec ce
syndicat entre l'état et le syndicat
concerné pour évidemment redresser les
finances accélérer les travaux
je le dis pour le président bon tarde de
me permettre de commencer à conjuguer
les réponses ça va permettre aussi
travaillé sur l'assainissement
parce que parfois on fait de grands
discours sur la biodiversité mais on
oublie que la principale source
destruction de la biodiversité
l'histoire outre à main sur tout
simplement les rejets des eaux grises
des eaux noires dans le lagon ou dans
les lagons et qu'on soit pas capable de
traiter de manière suffisamment
satisfaisantes l'eau je regarde les
services de saint barth des grands
enjeux que nous avons vu ces dernières
années avec le président bruno magra le
frère du sénateur que vous connaissiez
bien le prédécesseur de la sénatrice
c'était justement d'avoir une activité
entre piqué touristique tvr dans lequel
on était à peu près capable de savoir ce
qu ont rejeté dans le lagon pareil à
bora bora
personne ne peut imaginer un
développement touristique dans un lagon
qui serait qui ne serait pas
complètement transparent et donc ce que
l'on va accomplir sur l'eau avec le
syndicat à la mayotte vaut pour l'eau
potable vaut aussi pour l'assainissement
alors c'est pas glamour mais je reste
persuadé que mettre les questions
d'assainissement dans le dans le devant
de nos affaires sur les financements et
sur ce qu'on fait en matière de bio
discours conjuguer les deux réponses à
mon avis ces centrales enfin on pourra
toujours de raconter tout ce qu'on veut
sur la biodiversité n'a pas avec les
sujets là entre autres à toujours en
peine de crédibilité me semble-t-il
il s'agit d'avoir ce pacte des mesures
d'urgence
un audit du syndicat pour évidemment
bâtir le plan de redressement
et puis derrière évidemment des choses
sur la région équipements structurants
l' usine de dessalement
du dos vous l'avez dit vous l'avez
souligné station d'épuration et j'ai cru
comprendre à cannes ambitieux plan de
reboisement qui joue aussi sur la
ressource en eau et ait été envisagé
autant de sujets sur lesquels évidemment
je suis prêt à accompagner politiquement
en ingénierie et financièrement parce
que évidemment ça fait partie des grands
des grands sujets qui nous préoccupent
on y reviendra lors de mon prochain
déplacement à mayotte en fonction des
conditions sanitaires évidemment piste
longue
bon c'est un sujet qui nous est bien
connue maintenant
et pas de doute l'autorit pour
l'information de l'ensemble des
sénateurs comprendre la question du
sénateur c'est que on a effectivement
l'autorité environnementale qui agit
comme autorité indépendante a toujours
du mal à le comprendre mais comme vous
le savez c'est comme ça que ça
fonctionne a émis un certain nombre de
réserves on va dire comme ça sur sur
l'agrandissement cette liste longue pour
nous ça ne change pas notre regard sur
l'opportunité de la réaliser et sur le
bien fondé de vouloir cet investissement
je le dis parce que j'ai vu dans la
presse qu quelques doutes ici ou là
pouvait être évoquée donc ça ne change
pas la position du gouvernement
après est-ce qu'on va enjamber les
questions environnementales comme cela
en s'en moquant la réponse est non voilà
donc il faut qu'on trouve désormais les
solutions techniques qui évidemment va
entraîner peut-être des surcoûts et sur
lequel évidemment il faudra trouver des
réponses dans la clé de financement pour
répondre à ces surcoûts
est-ce qu'on renonce au projet la
réponse est non est-ce qu'on va enjamber
les questions environnementales
la réponse est non soixante personnes
envie d'aller en prison donc donc par
définition faut trouver des solutions à
ces problèmes mais ça me permet grâce à
vous de réaffirmer l'engagement du
président de la république et et notre
volonté d'y arriver
je pense que j'avais prenez votre
question sur mayotte et c'était
important
même la sénatrice de saint martin merci
de m'avoir accueillie chez vous il ya
encore quelques jours sur la
démonétisation du rsa je crois que le
conseil d'état n'est plus du tout
d'accord ça valait sur le volet de
l'expérimentation
mais je suis à quelque chose qui
pourrait être pérennisée dans neuf la
vidéo mais dans votre question
tel qu'on le mène actuellement pour le
coup ça on ne saura pas le faire parce
que aux yeux du conseil d'état ce ne
répond pas à la volonté initiale du
wisla teur de devoir rendre accessible
facilement un minima social
d'accompagnement dans la pauvreté
ça veut dire effectivement ça pose la
question de la de la prise de compétence
au caractère normatif par la
collectivité
je n'ai pas parlé avec la prison gibbs
comme je les ai vu la dernière fois moi
je suis prêt à mettre ce sujet sur la
table
jeu très direct et sans langue de bois
j'ai bien vu que la fermeture de la
frontière entre saint martin avec si une
partie pour des raisons liées aux que
vides
évidemment avait quand même montré
quelques comportements et donc la
question de la lutte contre la fraude au
rsa moi j'en fais un point majeur une
priorité majeure peut pas peut pas d'un
côté solliciter la solidarité nationale
et voir autant de gens qui en profitent
alors évidemment comme la présente
dindar canton étaient présents de
conseil départemental on a quelques
quelques sensibilité sur ces sujets de
fraudes avérées ça là dessus évidemment
vous accompagnera sa negras pas le débat
sur la recentralisation en outre-mer du
paiement du rsa à cet effet à la réunion
ça a été fait en guyane s'était fait à
mayotte
je sais qu aux antilles les questions se
posent là aussi il faudra aller traiter
je l'avais dis d'ailleurs à madame borel
lincertin et et au sénateur de
guadeloupe
les trois sénateurs de guadeloupe
dominique théophile victorin lurel
victoire n'est ce pas sûr aussi des
questions de recentralisation du rsa
évidemment en guadeloupe la chair ça a
été enfin tamponné à la fin des années
peu de temps avant les fêtes de noël et
donc on va pouvoir avoir une application
de cette affaire a tendu
je discute avec frédéric mais encore il
ya quelques quelques temps pour l'eau
courant mai 2021
donc il faudra sûrement prendre en face
publicité etc on explique cette affaire
parce que de fait il aperçoit qu on n'a
peut-être pas fait assez
monsieur le président on tard j'accélère
je suis bavard sur la biodiversité
bilité vous avez raison d'un sujet des
cloisonnements beaucoup de gens font des
choses très bien et que l'activité déjà
on l'oublié enfin elle lève l'impôt pour
les ems notamment les départements ou
les collectivités territoriales à
unifier donc quand même pas mal de
choses qui sont faites sur les espaces
naturels sensibles est à fait
remarquable on peut pas ne pas citer les
organismes de recherche et le monde
universitaire et puis on a les
opérateurs de l'état classique à la
réunion m'a été présenté ce que faisait
le nf en matière de bio dit
c'est absolument stupéfiant c'est
bluffant après les grands incendies
qu'on a pu connaître aussi ces dernières
années encore le plus récent sur lequel
je me suis rendu maïdo là aussi la
capacité à reconstituer les écosystèmes
on à savoir faire désormais quai qui est
tout à fait bluffant donc en fait c'est
assez rageant parce qu'on fait des
choses à miquelon aussi langue là donc
on m'avait aussi présenter des choses
tout à fait tout à fait significative et
qui n'était pas du tout anecdotique
je parle même pas de la région des
récifs coralliens sur lequel on commence
désormais avoir une maîtrise importante
[Musique]